foreign
ERS were talking about segments of the
show and how to make the show fun we had
a lot of real estate calls yesterday
that were coming in with uh Jade our
Ramsey personality and I were hosting
and James was like man it would be it'd
be cool Rachel if your husband came in
and answered some of these real estate
questions and I thought well
I don't know maybe I'll text and ask him
so I was like babe would you come in and
do an hour of the show and talk about
real estate on the Ramsay show and you
said
sure oh no I said let me think about it
let me think about it so we talked last
night so I wrote them in you guys this
is a first this is a first but I really
didn't want to have this discussion
because we talk about Building Wealth a
lot on this show and for a lot of people
especially our age and things I see on
social media Instagram Tick Tock all the
stuff
investment real estate is something that
people really are interested in and
they're they think it's kind of this get
rich quick and you see these numbers of
these Instagram
influencer Financial people like oh yeah
just go and borrow a bunch here and get
some rental houses and get some tenants
in and just passive income it's like the
easiest thing ever I make so much money
every month doing that and I'm sitting
there always listening knowing what you
go through when it comes to rentals and
real estate because you have your
license your you have a brokerage you've
been doing real estate for how long
um 10 12 years 10 12 years yeah
development and having tenants and all
that so yeah I kind of want to actually
uh I actually used to interrupt this
show while Dave was doing it and I'd run
downstairs and Pitch him a deal while he
was on air back in 2012 days yeah so I
it you know it's full circle now so now
I get to deliver all the mistakes and
wisdom that you want to know that's it
that's it okay but just to Bunk the high
level myth that like it's just so easy
all you do is just have a renter and
have passive income and that's it that's
it it's just it's mailbox money yeah now
I think the dream is easy and that's
what everybody gets sold on
um everybody gets sold on
this lifestyle that they see or could
imagine without having to necessarily
work yes and I think there's a
correlation between covid and the kind
of passive income quick money flip uh uh
phase and culture because I think it's
kind of fed this we can make life
whatever we want it to be and there
doesn't have to be any pain associated
with it yes and as with most things in
life especially with money there's
nothing like that that exists
unless you win the lottery and that's a
lot of gas station pain
um so it is a uh I think the dream is
easy but actually getting to this point
where you've got passive income takes a
long time and a lot of work and a lot of
headache and you're going to have gray
hairs and
um you're going to go through a lot of
crap to get there and um so it's it's
just not what you see on Instagram it's
not what you see on LinkedIn
um it's it takes a it takes a lot of
work and a lot of time that you
sometimes your lifestyle may not be set
up that way and honestly I don't know if
you if that should be a part of your
immediate goal it's all dependent on
your total Financial picture but
um it's it's not really an immediate
goal that you need to just have this
um
this income coming in the mailbox where
you don't have to do anything because it
is way harder than that and and the hard
comes from from your from you doing it
all these years is it from finding the
deal because that's one of the best ways
to do that if you get into real estate
investing once you have paid off your
your home you have no debt you have
savings retirement you do all the baby
steps the pain is it more on the front
ends of finding a good deal because you
talk about that buying a good deal on
the front end or is it the pain of
actually having the tenants
and having to manage maintenance the
people the rent I mean all of that yeah
no unless you're renting to a robot
um it's all all of it so uh when we were
when we were buying things it was every
30 offers you would get one contract
um and of those 30 offers most of them
weren't great deals
um and this was back in the recession in
2012 when people were begging for they
were begging for Deals they were begging
for a cash offer and it still took one
out of every 30. so uh it takes a ton of
time you got to be in the newspapers
looking for foreclosures you got to be
getting into the marketplace making
relationships with Brokers that that
will
um send you deals
um you got to be making relationships
with title companies to make sure that
you know and are aware of a clear title
when you're looking into something that
could be very risky so it's it's not a
it's not a um simple game and it's not a
risk-free game it's very risky it is a
huge financial decision but it should be
a part of your overall Financial picture
not the one thing the Silver Bullet that
allows you to not have to work yes
because I think that's it I think that's
that's the lie that we constantly try to
debunk on this show because again we get
these calls all the time of like well I
saw this and this and I want to you know
get have some rental properties and all
that but I'm like the amount of work the
amount of efforts to even find the deal
like you're saying it's a whole other
set of knowledge right that you can
learn I mean not that no one is that
you're not capable of it but it's not
this shoe-in easy access you know idea
of investing yeah yeah it really does it
takes so much work on the front and and
then once you do it again we we
encourage all cash so you're going to
start small move at the speed of cash uh
but then also too the the person in the
house or in the condo or in the town
home that's renting uh that's where
that's another risk that if you go and
take on debt
and get a bunch of rental properties
those people that you're depending on to
pay the mortgage plus maybe some more
yeah that may not always happen yeah so
and so I will say the other side of the
coin is
it's amazing so I'm not saying oh this
is all pain and terrible it's amazing
but and it is doable so
you're nice first uh rental property was
a was a condo uh for forty two thousand
dollars
and we saved up forty two thousand
dollars and bought this one bedroom
condo and it's not nice oh it's gross it
was awful you know you put ten thousand
dollars into it and rented it out and I
thought I had made it like I thought
this is it and then you start cashing
the checks and you're like oh
oh there's 700 oh that's pretty cool
that's pretty good 700 next month 700
next month
the 700 came in but the water heater
broke that's right and then you start
running that out you know over you know
every 12 months how much how much
rentaling can actually actually how much
rental income comes in
and then the actual expenses that it
takes to run that thing plus the amount
of people you have to deal with
and all of that headache chasing rent
um you're basically
netting it's tough a thousand bucks yeah
it's tough it's tough the amount no it
is now we did sell that condo four years
ago for 125 000 and that's the beauty of
it right but again that is it's long
term and difficult yeah so we are We Are
For Real Estate we come my that's that's
my dad's whole story obviously that this
helped with Ramsey Solutions is like was
in real estate he loves real estate
married a guy who loves real estate so
we are all for it but doing it the smart
way the right way and just to debunk
that it's not this like just easy shoe
and passive income that it's made to be
on social media